j'ai longtemps été nostalgique en
regardant cette image des terrasses de
café des marchands des enfants qui
jouent dans la rue tout ça qui se
mélangent des gens qui regardent la
scène urbaine au balcon et non pas
devant leur télé puis je regardais nos
villes réalisé que on en n'était plus du
tout là sa matrice fait mais après cinq
années à avoir travaillé avec des gens
exceptionnels à avoir eu la chance de
travailler sur des projets de
revitalisation urbaine
aujourd'hui j'ai espoir que ma fille va
un jour pouvoir vivre dans une ville
avec autant d'effervescence et je suis
ici aujourd'hui vous vous partager
l'espoir que j'ai retrouvé et pour vous
démontrer comment il serait possible de
réutiliser à grandeur nos villes sans
injecter davantage de fonds publics
voici dans quel cadre
on travaille tous aujourd'hui dans nos
villes on travaille dans des villes qui
entre à donner carte blanche à
l'automobile où on a transformé des
milieux de vie en des milieux de transit
où il fallait accéder rapidement au
centre-ville en automobile mais on a
oublié d'avoir des centres villes
aujourd'hui le grand défi c'est de les
reconstruire de redonner à la population
les bords de rivières les villes
s'attaque à ce grand défi à coup de
grands projets urbains d'intérêt général
mais il ya une échelle que ces grands
projets de rénovation urbaine n'est pas
capable d'adresser en tout cas de
l'intéressé beaucoup plus difficilement
c'est la notion de revitalisation comme
dans redonner la vie qu'est ce qui donne
la vie si les gens le quotidien les
dynamiques économiques sociales
culturelles les échanges
ça se passe dans l'humain ça se passe
pas dans le pavé un très bon exemple
qu'on a tendance d'utiliser d'utiliser
ces berlin berlin qui est un cas extrême
d'une ville qui a dû entièrement se
reconstruire après la chute du mur
ce que la ville a fait ses réponses
à coup de grands projets une image de
métropole qu'elle avait perdu mais le
défi était tellement grand il y avait
tellement d' espaces vacants que la
ville c'est juste ouvert aux habitants
puis chaque petit projet était le
bienvenu un espace délaissé poser des
problèmes de sécurité
un espace délaissé qui était pris en
main par un habitant par un entrepreneur
devenu une étincelle de vie devenue une
opportunité et à grandeur
tous ces petits projets en redessiner
une image d'une ville qui est l'image
que tout le monde a envie de berlin
actuellement une ville et est
reconstruit par sa population
c'est une ville qui est même reconstruit
par ses enfants c'est un parc de
quartier à berlin imaginez un peu vos
enfants qui toute la semaine rêve d'être
le week-end pour pouvoir aller
construire leur cabane dans leur parc
c'est les futurs citoyens qui seront
impliqués dans nos villes imaginer ce
que ça leur apporte du point de vue de
la formation de l'ouverture de la
créativité de l'espoir c'est un peu avec
cet espoir que ce regard d'enfant que je
suis arrivé à montréal il ya cinq ans et
que j'ai vu un grand terrain
d'opportunité
montréal est une ville très créative qui
a envie de créer qui une ville qui
s'ouvre à tous petits projets parce
qu'une ville qui sait qu'elle a des
problèmes de vitalisation dans certains
espaces j'ai été je tombais totalement
amoureux du canal lachine de ces espaces
post industrielle sous-exploité et puis
un moment j'ai juste voulu faire quelque
chose avec une association de designers
on appris le site que vous voyez au
milieu de l'écran puis le temps d'une
journée
on a fait venir tout le monde qu'on
connaissait on a fait un appel à projets
dans nos amis d'amis d'amis puis on a
fait venir une vingtaine de designers
qui chacun ont construit un petit
morceau de cet espace
on a fait venir des foutraque on a
ouvert un bar et puis tout ça avait une
allure un peu ça partait dans tous les
sens c'était pas forcément magnifique
mais il y avait une énergie incroyable
et en fait on a réalisé que cette
énergie était faite parce qu'on était
une vraie communauté des amis d'amis
d'amis qui avaient contribué à
construire un lieu et s'était rendu
compte
que même avec des efforts très près ce
que très petit on était capable de
reconstruire cette image de se
réapproprier les lieux ce qui était une
expérience du de simplement une journée
dans laquelle on a investi 10 mille
dollars qui ont été refinancés par la
vente d'alcool donc aucun fonds publics
n'ont été injecté on s'est dit on la
fait vivre à la communauté du design
on voudrait faire vivre la population
donc on a pris un autre site en ville
sur lequel on pouvait rester deux mois
puis à bras à bras le corps on a fait
vivre ce site pendant deux mois avec une
activité culturelle met toutes sortes de
journée et finalement un projet qui a
coûté des coûts faramineux à notre
échelle on n'aurait jamais pensé que ce
projet coûterait 150 mille dollars
il a coûté que 10000 dollars de fonds
publics une maigre subvention qu'on a eu
et on a été capable de lever 150 mille
dollars
totalement autofinancée personne n'a
perdu ses maisons dans l'équation
on a été capable d'accueillir trente
cinq mille visiteurs et de vraiment
offrir à la population ce lieu la
population venait dans les lieux et ça
nous a permis de grandir de manière
organique
l'année d'après on est revenu encore
plus longtemps un projet encore deux
fois plus coûteux deux fois plus de
visiteurs
dix fois plus de sable on donne à la
population ce qu'elle veut et puis au
delà de l'aménagement on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait comblé un manque des
comparaisons avec werlen ressortez
souvent parce que les gens venaient et
et ressentez un sentiment de liberté
dans ces lieux
c'est une autre manière d d'occuper
l'espace public on avait créé un espace
public alternatif où on avait défini nos
propres règles étaient en fait l'absence
de règles on a tellement l'habitude dans
l'espace public de se balader avec un
verre à la main de manière illégale de
trouver difficilement des lieux où nos
enfants peuvent s'amuser et nous aussi
ou on peut amener nos chiens est en fait
en l'absence de règles on avait créé un
lieu où simplement les gens respectaient
le lieu les gens là se l'approprier avec
une énergie avec une liberté
même les adultes devenaient des grands
enfants
et les enfants eux-mêmes utiliser des
choses qui avait pas du tout été conçus
comme des jeux pour en faire des jeux
c'est l'appropriation de tout ce qui a
donné lieu ça qui a donné vie à ce lieu
est petite anecdote c'est la police nous
a dit que c'était un lieu qui posait des
graves problèmes de délinquance
avant on est arrivés dans lieux on a
effacé toutes les règles et nous ont dit
que depuis deux ans qu'on était là il
avait plus aucun problème il n'est plus
jamais quand il venait c'était pour
profiter de la plage et au delà de ça
collectivement parce que c'est tous les
projets que vous montrez ont été faits
avec énormément d'intervenants
collectivement on a redonné espoir à la
population lui un mot qui ressort
énormément cet ancien montréal c'est les
possibles révélée possible
comment on avait été capable de
démontrer qu'on pouvait à nouveau faire
des projets on pouvait faire plein de
petits projets avec peu de moyens et
avant tout des projets qui se passe
maintenant pas dans cinq ans les villes
font des grands projets de rénovation
nécessaires à grands coups à grand
budget nous on n'a pas de budget mais on
fait des lieux dans lesquels on veut
être en l'absence de budget la
contrainte de la contrainte n'est la
créativité ont fait plus avec moins on
s'attaque pas à des choses faramineuses
on met des lampes dans les airs
7 ce plafond lumineux a peut-être coûté
200 dollars et à créer un événement les
gens regarder en l'air on était content
que les gens regardent en l'air parce
que au sol c'était de l'asphalté pas
beau mais il regarde en l'air il était
heureux
c'est avec cette idée de simplement
venir dans les lieux et delhaize
approprié de les humaniser qu'on s'est
aussi attaqué à cette ruelle salle
malodorantes avec des problèmes de
délinquance et on est simplement venu
l'approprier avec des éléments très
simple des bacs de plantation des
lumières ikea et c'est drôle parce que
le jour où on est inauguré ce lieu il ya
une dame qui faisait son trajet
quotidien qui est un moment s'est
retrouvé face à man m'a presque heurter
puis à fait aux mondiaux je vous tromper
de chemin
elle passait là tous les jours mais là
et s'est rendu compte que le lieu
ressemble plus du tout elle n'aurait
jamais pu penser que ce lieu avec si peu
de moyens
deviennent redeviennent humains pour le
prix d'une étude de marché
on est capable de construire le marché
et c'est drôle parce qu on est arrivé
dans ce quartier puis on s'est rendu
compte que depuis cinq ans il ya des
groupes communautaires cinq articles à
des gros problèmes de sécurité
alimentaire
il n'y a pas de supermarché
d'accessibilité de produits frais à un
kilomètre à la ronde
alors que les premières terres agricoles
sont à deux kilomètres au nord ça
faisait cinq ans que des organismes
communautaires faisait des marchés des
petits marchés dans leur coin essayer de
développer ce discours sur la sécurité
alimentaire
l'arrondissement aussi y penser puis ce
projet s'est juste fait il était là il
c'est un projet pilote il était là pour
un an est finalement là on parle de le
garder pour les cinq prochaines années
on avait nos bureaux dans l'atelier de
cet artiste dont vous voyez les
sculptures puis un jour cet artiste
cherchait un endroit pour exposer ses
oeuvres comme un artiste qui auraient
des tableaux qui les exposeraient dans
un café pour se donner une vitrine puis
les vendre puis la réaliser on a un parc
linéaire devant notre atelier qui fait
un kilomètre de long il a appelé
l'arrondissement qui leur a proposé il a
leur a proposé de juste exposer ses
oeuvres dans le parc
ce parc linéaire d'un kilomètre de long
qui était principalement un lieu de
transit est devenue une grande galerie à
ciel ouvert simplement par un échange de
bons procédés
on est intervenu dans ce projet pour en
phase et cette dynamique et fait
ressortir la créativité qu'il y avait
dans ses ateliers d'artistes pour venir
offrir à la population un lieu pour se
rencontrer et c'est devenu simplement
parce que la ville a donné le terrain
un lieu d'expression et de rencontre
pour la communauté locale
un lieu qui résume très bien toute cette
démarche et la place mii ghana sur la
commune et la chance pour développer une
vision dans les années 70 c'était un
grand stationnement
dix ans après pour l'anniversaire de la
ville de montréal ils ont ils ont rénové
pour en faire un nouveau une nouvelle
place publique
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya pas eu
un effort de revitalisation pendant
vingt ans la place a été abandonnée est
devenu un repère pour la délinquance le
trafic de drogue et l'itinérance les
sans abri quand on est arrivés dans le
projet la regarder autour puis on s'est
dit c'est drôle il ya plein de
créativité de choses qui se passent
d'intervention d'organismes qui
gravitent autour de cette place mais
ça n'a pas d'impact sur la place en fait
à part les l'université les étudiants
qui utilisaient la place pour manifester
ben là ils ont juste utiliser la place
pour s'exprimer pour expérimenter les
organismes locaux qui depuis des années
faisait des grands desgrandchamps
d'agriculture urbaine
on les a fait venir sur la place qu'ils
ont planté 500 mètres carrés de légumes
la grande bibliothèque c'est juste
ouverte sur la place pour venir faire
des conférences le quartier latin avec
une ambiance festive ap recoller sur le
lieu et c'est devenu un lieu festif les
bureaux vingt mille travailleurs autour
utiliser la place pour les lunchs et le
midi et ce qu'ils étaient avant un
espace relativement délaissé avec des
problèmes est devenu un lieu
d'effervescence et un vrai repère pour
la communauté
c'est un lieu qui a vécu parce que il y
avait une âme dans ce lieu qui était
notamment tenu par cette jardinière qui
étaient là à temps plein et qui parlait
avec la population pour leur expliquer
comment planter qui transmettait qui
parlait aux sans abri qui montrait aux
sans abri comment planter et comment
récolter les fruits qu'ils avaient
planté les sans abri qui avant était vu
comme un problème pour la ville sont
devenus une part de la solution parce
que la nuit en dormant sur le site et
regardait le potager y protéger le
potager qu'ils avaient planté c'est
aussi devenu un lieu de fierté parce que
le gérant du parc était lui-même un
ancien sans abri et il parlait avec
cette population
c'est ces gens là qui font l'âme du lieu
ça c'est un marché qui était tenue par
les l'université qui était à côté donc
on lit l'ont pas ils ont utilisé cette
vitrine pour pouvoir apprendre
expérimenté s'ouvrir au grand public et
en même temps c'est un quartier qui a
besoin d'avoir des accès aux produits
frais on est encore dans une démarche
donnant donnant et c'était un grand lieu
de rencontre de communion collective
ça c'est le karaoké qui se tenait tous
les dimanches il y avait autant des
hipsters que dès que des sans abri que
des gens qui venaient d'arriver de
l'aéroport et tout le monde se mélange
et d'injuste un esprit de partage puis
le karaoke il y avait c'est quand même
un programme qui coûte pas cher à mettre
en place les gens c'est le public qui
fait le spectacle
ce qui est le plus important c'est que
chaque site qui est délaissé en ville a
un potentiel économique ce qui fait que
ces projets peuvent peuvent fonctionner
avec si peu d'investissement public
c'est parce qu'on est capable de venir y
mettre une activité économique 7
terrasses en fête et un café bar
restaurant qui permet de financer une
partie des aménagements notre projet de
plage au pied du pont jacques cartier
est financé à plus de 85% par le bar
c'est comme une taxe à la source si vous
venez si vous aimez le lieu vous fait
grandir le lieu on diversifie les
activités économiques avec des marchés
qui permettent aussi de mettre en valeur
des micro-entrepreneurs maintenant
pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça
pourquoi j'ai espoir qu'on puisse
revitalise à grandeur la ville c'est
parce qu'on a pensé qu' il ya deux
sortes de lois de pourcentage qui sont
utilisés pour compenser les choses la
taxe carbone le 1% en art public
pourquoi on ne parlerait pas d'un pour
cent de revitalisation urbaine pourquoi
chaque grand projet de réussite de
rénovation urbaine n'aiderait pas à
financer d une multitude de petits
projets de revitalisation urbaine un
exemple un grand projet d'une échelle de
50 millions on parle souvent d'échelle
en dizaines de millions pour les grands
projets de rénovation ont fait une
réduction de 1 % 1 % du coût de ce
projet ci permet de faire une économie
de 500 mille dollars et d'investir dans
dix petits projets de revitalisation
urbaine
si on l'appliquait la ville voici une
ville voici trois grands projets de
rénovation urbaine à d'une échelle de 50
millions de dollars
et voici tous les petits projets de
revitalisation urbaine que ça peut créer
grâce à ce 1% d'investissement
revitalisation urbaine et la grande
image de la ville
la complémentarité entre ces deux permet
de faire la grande revitalisation
d'atteindre notre objectif de renforcer
les identités de quartier de créer des
vitrine culturelle et de faire une ville
bâtie par et pour ses habitants
et c'est dans cette ville que j'espère
que ma fille va grandir